okay good morning everyone it's nine
o'clock on the west coast I'm Alex
Foucault director the bd2k centers
Coordination Center today we're
continuing Section four on data modeling
in at ferns methods and one type of
method that some of you may have already
encountered here studies of work or at
least heard of are related to patient
techniques so I have the pleasure of
introducing professor Michael min
professor statistics and assessments and
medical informatics at University of
Wisconsin Madison that's great
dr. noon is an associate director of the
Center for predictive computational
phenotyping cpct C one of the National
bd2k Centers of Excellence dr. Newman
has led many novel applications of
statistical techniques and algorithms on
biomedical big data for instance he was
the first to use Markov chain Monte
Carlo and phylogenetic analysis as well
as the use of mixed models for analyzing
high dimensional gene expression changes
long-standing interest of Professor moon
is in the area of based on empirical
Bayesian computations and he'll be
talking to us today about Bayesian
inference methods so please join me in
welcoming dr. noon this morning Michael
thank you for joining us the floor is
yours
thank you Alex well hello everybody it's
great to be here thanks for tuning in I
do hope you find something useful in
today's webinar
so the pics on this first slide show or
signifies some projects and activities
that I've been involved in in my own
work and thus they may show up in
examples as we go through today
well basically inference is a big deal
lots of researchers have thought a lot
about it and how it can be used to
advantage in data analysis there are a
few books on the topic and I encourage
you to take a closer look Michael today
is
to be sort of a cheerleader for Bayesian
methods pointing out some of their basic
features and also some opportunities in
this new world of data science but in
addition to my job there's some things
for you to do too you can join the
Society for Bayesian analysis you can
check out the American Statistical
Association section you can check out
online the journal Bayesian analysis you
could in fact visit Duke University
where one of the strong centers for
Bayesian inference and researching these
techniques you could check out some code
andrew gell-mann's originated this
terrific code project called stan that
delivers some really useful techniques
for AI software techniques for deploying
Bayesian analysis so that's some of the
things you can do I'm going to just give
you a bit of an overview of what
Bayesian analysis is so I'm going to
keep features about it and how it goes
in some examples so it's a general
strategy for data analysis and based on
probability and the key thing about a
visit couples data with some kind of
model specification and that model
specification has two features it's got
a probability structure for the data
themselves given unknown things
this reflects kind of the central dogma
of statistics that all data sets are the
realization of some random process and
encoding that in probability is kind of
central but then a second part of it has
to do with all the unknown parameters
say and there's some probability
structure on that to that's a special
part of Bayesian analysis is essentially
expands the domain of probability to be
a general measure of uncertainty and
then inference about what we don't know
given what we know is is precedes using
the rules of probability okay well I'm
going to talk about a few sort of
relevant examples but I wanted to start
with that kind of irrelevant example but
it's still pedagogically interesting
about some text so here's a little video
I'm doing an experiment to collect some
data I'm tossing a thumbtack and it
noticed that I taught that tack and it
landed with its point facing down I
replicated that experiment again and I
tossed the tack and it happened to land
with its
point facing up and and this was the
beginning of a longer experiment that I
did with 50 trials that outcome was of
which the full dataset is shown here I
got my 50 trials it turned out 17 times
that the attack landed with its top side
with its point facing down now we know
from the large numbers that the relative
frequency at which the tackle answer
that's a tipping point facing down that
D over N at relative frequency is uh
well let's random variable for one thing
but also it stabilizes in the long run
if I were to have continued the
experiment tossing tacks indefinitely it
would converge to something we'll call
theta the long-run relative frequency of
times that the attack glance with its
head pointing down that's a parameter of
the system a property of attacking
experimental system and it's an unknown
underlying parameter underneath the data
set so we could of course estimate that
unknown theta with 7950 34% but but at
issue really are in in our focus our
asking more general inference questions
such as what are plausible values of
that parameter having observed 17 it's
hot Headz attack points down in 50 tests
and rather than go through the mass of
it i just wanted to present this answer
this question a Bayesian would answer
but through a simulation so in this
first part of the simulation suppose we
happen to know this long run relative
frequency theta if we did we could surly
run the experiment in the computer and
replicate it so let me this little panel
shows it's sort of setup to understand
replications of this little tac tossing
experiment I've got possible values of
theta on the on the horizontal and I've
got possible values of data on that
vertical and the observed value of the
data the 17 times if the tech face
pointing down out of 50 trials now look
at the little code chunk up in the upper
right here this is my in silico
experiment I could fix their differences
if I knew it I'd say 60 percent and set
up this little code which just is a way
of using random
it's a pseudo-random numbers and the
computer to simulate the tack tossing
without actually tossing the tack 50
times but this is a replicate of that if
I knew that long-run relative frequency
and I happen when I do that to get about
26 now since it's a simple bit of code I
can repeat it obviously I can repeat it
and look I did it about a thousand times
this this represents the so called
sampling distribution lists you'll
recognize the binomial sampling
distribution of the relative of the
values of the number of of point down
tax out of 50 centered around 60 percent
of 50 around 30 but with some
fluctuation I notice that the value
observed value 17 doesn't look very
plausible for that dataset but in that
little you know and that's basically a
problem with this little simulation I've
I've had to pretend I know the value of
this unknown parameter well in fact I
don't now if I do that simulation I
could just change it a little bit if you
look up here I just as I imagined what
data I might have happened I might have
gotten let me also vary the value of the
parameter theta by just grabbing a
uniformly distributed theta every time
and on that uniformly distributed theta
then go ahead and simulate my outcome of
my my experiment this is what you get if
you do it about a thousand times
now now what's round in gray there is
these are hypothetical repetitions of
experiments that I've set up in this
two-stage experiment where the simulated
data actually exactly the same as the
data that I happen to see in my real
experiment so surely those values of
those parameters that gave rise to those
state those simulated data must be
plausible because in light of the data
that I saw they could easily have given
rise to the same data as we saw in the
simulation so that is the essence of
what Bayesian analysis is it's looking
at the distribution of those theta
values now we've conditioned it
effectively on that 17 and we can
project down onto the theta axis right
now and so I just take another boost at
the simulation size up a bit but this is
the this distribution of
satyrs have came out of this experiment
where I first similarly theta and then I
get simulated data given theta but then
I keep a track of the Thetas that match
my observed data these are certainly
plausible values well indeed
mathematically we can work out the
formula for that curve it's known as the
posterior distribution it's functional
form is known and it expresses a kind of
uncertainty in the value of theta that
would have generated the data we saw but
uncertainty expressed after the data
haven't been seen that's to contrast it
with the uncertainty that we expressed
in this little simulation before the
data were seen
remember that our unif what the state of
values are before
what's theta values I'm considering is
relevant in advance of having seen the
data and this connection the connection
the famous formula that the posterior is
proportional to the prior times the
likelihood is likely now coming from the
binomial model in our case the OS way
back to Thomas Bayes himself now looking
at that functional form this is the this
thing this beast is the is the object
that it's critical for inference so we
could take we don't know that theta we
have a summary of our uncertainty about
it if we take the center value then the
mean of that distribution its expected
value that could serve as a point
estimate and then that happens in this
case at the balance point of the
distribution is a little different than
the what you think of us the natural
estimator 17 over 50 it's it's a little
bit modified it's as we say shrunken
towards the prior mean which is a half
compared to the MLE we could also get an
interval that contains a certain amount
of that posterior probability so that's
that's how it would go in this little
toy example now let's take a a second
let's to example intestinal tumors now
here the data aren't outcomes of attack
throwing experiment but their outcomes
of looking at side the looking inside
the DNA of polyps that were found during
colonoscopy of men study its detectable
pathogenic mutations from 36 colon like
polyps there's the data here the heart
the horizontal corresponds to the 36
different subjects in the study the
vertical are the rows correspond to
different pathogenic mutations that were
measured assessed by sequencing
different genes that are known to be
critically involved in the development
of colon cancer that's the data these
are detectable so they have to have
appeared at a sufficiently high
frequency and the sequencing of the
tumor this comes from a recent
publication by Chelsea Severson rich
Albert's a group here medicine ok now I
have to give before I tell a bit about
the model I have to say something about
colon cancer progression the this little
cartoon on the left shows the wall of
just a tiniest segment of the wall of
the intestinal epithelium and the green
piece here is been converted it's it's
initiated to be its non normal and it's
starting to become cancerous the polyps
are essentially at this stage the data
is coming at this stage early abnormal
growth outside of this structure here
and eventually if things go wrong you'll
get a cancer but the data that we're
talking about our data early added on
the stage I also want to point out a
basic structural unit of the intestinal
wall that's expressed here in
cross-section in this cartoon the
intestinal wall is made up of these
millions I guess of these barrel shaped
glands called crypts there are actually
thousands of cells not just a handful of
cells here and they're clonal so
essentially they all come from stem
cells at the bottom of the this space
that they have they're from a single
lineage that's going to be important
then something I'll say later there they
are from the single lineage and there
they're the basic structural unit of the
intestine like I said and also tumors
when they started for initially adenoma
see emerge out of these crypts and they
start to grow there's all bunch of
interesting things about crypt biology I
won't say but the Crypt itself is going
to be important thank for my story so
okay so previously we tossed tacks in
silico but now instead of tossing tacks
in silico i'm going to do a simulation
of tumor growths it's a discrete step
simulation it's not cells that are shown
here but actually crypts that proceed
and this evolved by a certain stochastic
model that you can read about in the
paper essentially crypts may fission
they turn into multiple grips or they
could potentially die and also the
crypts these clone bodies may incur
certain mutations as they go along the
colors that you may be able to see here
there's different colors correspond to
different mutations that have occurred
and then growing out so this is a
interesting thing so it's not tossing
attack but it's growing at a tumor now
well what could see but what did savers
do they would simulate these tumors and
then they mimicked the sampling process
they did an in silico section of the
tumor looked at the clones that the
crypts inside basically we're trying to
match what they observed here with our
observed data on the 36 in the Seavers
paper they do something very light
instead of conditioning on all 36 they
just ask a very very simple question oh
it's a little bit different than
finishing all the data they just asked
at the level of a mutation that you
would see in here does the frequency at
which that mutation occur does it exist
at a sufficiently high frequency to be
detected by the next-generation
sequencing technology that's used and
there's lower threshold was that the
mutant frequency had to be a bigger than
10% in order for the sequencing to
observe is it a detectable mutation now
ideally in fact we would simulate not
just one tumor up to check for its
mutations but we would simulate a sample
of these polyps or tumors and you'd wait
and you'd see if they if the mutation
profile and slices of these things
matched our observed sample we don't do
that severs didn't do that but I just
point to interested observers to this
paper just came out earlier this week by
marjoram group that that does
essentially that kind of a calculation
in any case in the simple calculation
that we're talking about where we
simulate up instead of tossing attack
we're simulating up a tumor that's
growing in the intestine through a
stochastic model of how tumors might
grow the and we look at a mutation
that's
shown up at the time that we observed
the tumour the quantity of interest in
Seavers paper was the size of the tumor
in crypts when the mutation that we're
looking at happened to have emerged so
when we see if it's observation time we
get to see a mutation at some frequency
but that mutation must have emerged in
the tumor growth sometime before we got
to observe it that time isn't known to
the observer that's the parameter theta
SMU and they're the simulations were
exempt so that these tumors mutations
can emerge at any time along they can
emerge them any time and sense of any
size that the tumor is this is growing
but if we conditioned on the data so to
speak that we conditioned on the fact
that the mutation is actually existed
sufficiently high frequency to be
detectable when we measure it then we
get a posterior distribution of the size
of the tumor when that mutation arose in
and looking at these kind of
distributions tells us that these
detectable mutations must have arisen
when the chamber was actually quite
small and you can go to specific
inferences about that so that's an
interesting variation of the simulation
story where instead of simulating tax
we're simulating tumors but the same
story you simulate unknown things data
on simulated it until that data is equal
or approximately equal to the observed
data that you have and you keep a track
of the quantity theta that corresponds
to it the simulation view of the
Bayesian inference was one of the number
of terrific insights made by Dan Rubin
in his paper that I recommend had
everybody on frequency calculations that
are relevant for Bayesian analyst it's
also the basis of what people are not
call approximate Bayesian computation
that's especially useful in situations
where likelihood functions are
intractable such as in population
genetics or in other forms of ancestral
inference okay so that's just a little
supposed to whet your appetite about
Bayes from a simulation perspective I
want to talk about three main features
of Bayes going forward now
with the rest of my time so I want to
talk about three basic things handling
uncertainty combining different data
sources and wearing strengths and I'll
use three different case study examples
to illustrate these features of Bayesian
inference so let's go forward and lis
uncertainty so this is one of the sort
of basic features of Bayes that you know
that we're always you know we understand
that data doesn't tell us all the
information even if it's big data it
doesn't have four things were interested
about it may not contain all the
information so we have to be able to
express our uncertainty about things
that we don't quite know and basis
rigged up for that so let's say and then
in addition to a pair of theatres that
we we might understand there's some
other parameters side and Bayes
procedure somehow or other through a
model specification gives rise to a
joint posterior distribution of all the
unknowns given the data that we have
well if we're really just interested in
theta somehow then
Michael we're having problems with the
audio could you please check your
microphone
hello hello
ah either back I think that that sounds
better okay well should I back up some I
mean I don't know how far along I was we
lost you for actually a few minutes so
maybe you just back up a little bit that
would be good okay sorry about that I
don't know quite what happened let's see
if I can back up here okay did we give
me a sign here do we know about this
part I think that's good okay so the
handling uncertainty part I'm going to
try and talk about in the context of an
example that'd be a good place to kick
back in balance okay okay sorry folks
well yeah so this handling uncertainty
I'm going to talk about in an example
from RNA interference this genome wide
technology for understanding gene
functions and just briefly about that
and you've seen the slides with didn't
hear me say it's a cell-based assay the
basic idea is you have a target gene
that you're targeting with a given si
RNA you add that si RNA small
interfering RNA to the cells and what's
supposed to do is knock down the
expression of that gene and if that
targeted gene is involved in some
phenotype that you're measuring then
that phenotype will change and the cell
is what's changed as I've indicated with
the red now and in the story we're
talking about the phenotype has to do
with the cell's ability to replicate
virus there were four large-scale
studies that use this technology
genome-wide and we had data on on parts
of these studies there are all the
studies of interesting similarity there
were two state studies with a detection
screen and a confirmation screen a whole
genome was what was every every one of
the genes different srna's were used to
try to knock down things and anything
that passed the detection screen went
into a confirmation screen that it was
more intensive but it only had to be
applied to the things that were detected
initially remember the detection has to
do with whether or not the phenotype
here is whether or not is
when it's infected with virus and you
knocked down the Jane whether that I
changed the cells ability to make virus
and one of the curious things here as in
other examples is is that this each as I
was saying each of the studies made
about 200 genes found about 200 genes
that they said when you knock him down
it affects the cell's ability to
replicate virus but only one gene was
found in common doll for studies few
genes were found in three of the four
studies some in two of the four but the
majority of genes that were identified
and reported as involved in flu were
uniquely identified in one study only it
could be because of false positives
measurement errors one but off targets
is a big possibility where you add the
si RNA and there's a change in the cell
as indicated by the pink but actually
the gene that that si RNA is targeted
isn't really involved in flu at all it's
just that the si RNA accidentally and
not by design happens to knock down
another gene that is involved in flu and
then you see the phenotype even though
you shouldn't have really it could also
be false negatives and there's a bunch
possible false negative results one
pasta where it's just the genes really
involved in flu but you're somehow not
able to see it when you do the sa RNAi
screen for instance you IDs a RNAi
screen to knock down the gene that's
really involved in flu but somehow or
other there's another gene sitting there
that's doing the job of the first scene
in those particular cells and so even
though the team one has been knocked
down and is really involved you don't
see a phenotypic effect in those cells
there's the various other forms for the
negatives and positives but the big
issue was whether or not it was where
which is which is the source of
disagreement if if false positives were
really a big deal you wouldn't be
surprised to see the lack of agreement
these studies just pulling up a bunch of
random genes and so it wouldn't be
surprising that you wouldn't have much
agreement at the same time it could be
that the flu is really a big complicated
thing and in each of the studies really
is just seeing a small part of it
and since July those single since really
are true so as I was saying here so to
bring it back to the context of Bayesian
analysis we have a probability model for
the data we were able to compile in the
data that were able to compile is a kind
of meta analysis of what happened see
each gene across each of the studies
whether or not it was detected and
whether or not it was confirmed we have
counts for instance how many genes or
four genes that were detected in the
first study and confirmed they were
detection the second study not confirmed
and they weren't detected in the second
two studies naturally a multinomial
likelihood M that's the green it's the
data that we have detection and
confirmation information but we don't
know a lot of things we don't know
whether the genes really involved in flu
we don't know if it's accessible or if
there's redundancies in that case we
don't know off targets in that study for
those s hearing aids used and we don't
know a bunch of things generally about
the system as a whole the rates of
measurement error and efficiency
we have bits of information about that
but all those things we don't know we
can collect we can put our heads
together and try and figure out a
probability model that links together
all those things we don't know with what
we know you often see these these
director basically graphical
representations of probability models to
express dependencies and that's what
that is here so and we use the tools of
Bayesian analysis to come up with a
probability distribution of the unknowns
given what we do see well so we are
going into details of how the
calculations go ahead we work out our
joint posterior distribution and then we
come down to the statement of marginal
posterior distributions on quantities
that were actually directly interested
in these error rates so for example
theta1 is a quantity of interest it's a
false discovery range it's asking it's a
something we don't know in advance
really it's the chance that the gene
would really be involved in flu if in
fact it was confirmed in the study is it
that's a it's the chance that the gene
is not involved in fluid that's the
ideas are given that it's confirmed so
if it's confirmed what's the chance it's
not involved that's a false discovery
rate it's a this is a kind of a false
positive rate well
we don't know that false positive rate
but in our calculation we get a
posterior distribution for the false
positive rate that's way down here and
similarly we get a distribution for the
false negative rate and this and some
other similar calculations basically
they have accounted for all the
uncertainty and all those many many
things we didn't know in the context of
a specific probability specification and
it tells us pretty unequivocally that
false negatives are a bigger problem
than false positives and that lines up
with some other other analyses of the
same data but that's an example of using
marginal posterior is to to get a
particular quantities of interest and
address those ok I want to move on to
another example combining data this is
where so one of the big things about
base is that you can combine multiple
data sources so I'm going to talk about
different data X&Y coming together to
make inference this is a story about
cancer and it's based on this amazing
crude creature called an aggregation
chimera that is formed from two early
embryos that are fused together and
plant it into a foster mother and then
once in a while if it all works right
you get some animal out that's really
two separate animals more or less merge
together for parents here's a chunk of
an intestinal epithelium I've sent one
of these animals it's also been
significantly engineered to be
susceptible to growing tumors their
intestine and it's blue and white color
owing to the two separate parental
lineages this is the Blues come from one
side and the whites come from another
now curiously in the middle it's a
little hard to see but in the middle is
it it's a tumor and what's especially
curious about it is that it's it's two
colors it's blue and white about 20% in
fact of the tumors and this animals are
hetero typic now if the standard story
about biology cancer growth which of
course we can't well that's one of cool
things about cancer research is that we
and statistics for cancer research that
you're talking about events
before you were able to observe them but
the standard story about tumors growing
out of crypts crypts being clonal
doesn't work here because if it did they
would be either pure white as the cells
in one lineage come or either white or
pure blue but they wouldn't be mixed
together so this is a kind of a poly
clone ality story now there's a bunch of
interesting crime statistic alysha's of
the polyclinic i just want to focus on
one specific one that about the
combining information sources so one
information source is to do with the
patchwork of the cell tissue of this
lineage some of the cells come from one
only it's one of the organs in embryos
some come from the other so that
password a beautiful patchwork that
presents itself now we'd like to know in
order to have an understanding of tumor
initiation events we'd like to know
where the crypts are under there but we
don't get to see those now on the other
hand there's something well just back up
they there's something about the imaging
technique that is not able to reveal the
positions of the crypts in the
blue-white images now there's data on
other animals that aren't animals that
are American animals but there's data on
other animals or at least they're not
blue white image animals let's show what
these crypts organization look like so
we'd like to kind of merge few as this
day that with this data somehow and
that's what the analysis that will show
that tries to do we the reason we want
to do this is because we're trying to
understand how how many pairs of crypts
are really on edges between blue and
white that could potentially give rise
to these polyclonal tumors well so the
data on one side the X is a pixel image
a blue-eyed image the unknown quantity
theta
yeah the positions that we record as
centers of positions of crypts and it's
easy with some simple image analysis I
just to work out of likely if you knew
where the Crips were what's the
probability of seeing a particular image
you know that scripts are pure blue or
white there would be some flip error at
some small rate which would flip a pixel
if it's supposed to be white it might be
blue and then if you're a pixel that's
not over
you might be coming up by a background
rate so that's a one part now we also
have other a second data source I was
saying about the positions of Crips not
in the data that we're interested in
blue-eyed image but in another source we
can triangulate that image and look at
those points they're not scattered
uniformly randomly around in fact they
have quite a bit of spatial structure
that we can express with the kind of a
spatial model on positions where we use
the actual entry point distances to get
an estimate of this potential function
for the Joint Distribution of spatial
positions so we try put that together we
use the external data Y to tell us about
what kind of patterns we might expect to
see in the Crips orientation theta and
we we want to use that to get we take
the blue-white image to together to try
and figure out what the [ __ ] position
might have been in fact this is one
sample from the posterior distribution
of the crit position that I blow up here
and I've colored the Crips either blue
or white depending on the depth majority
color of the pixels above them and the
key thing had to do with these red edges
these are neighboring crypts that are of
opposite color and so if a tumor might
emerge from crypts nearby like that
there would be a certain rate at which
that happens that we can estimate and
then so based on this we could get some
idea about what the interaction distance
might be in between crypts that are at
the origin of polyclonal turned
polyclonal Turner's okay that's a quick
run-through of combining information and
in the last part I wanted in the last
few minutes talk about borrowing
information borrowing strength
information sharing this is a big deal
engine at least you've got possibly many
different but related inference problems
there am of them and I've got Thetas are
the unknown parameters in each one and
each one gives rise to a data set
they're separate but related in some
sense now there's two cases I we may the
problems may be linked by some other
parameters i we don't know any other
theta to the size we get the data now
it's a
classic result going a long time ago
that if you're interested in inference
about the sighs I don't know linking
parameter you could screw up even if you
get lots and lots of data your standard
estimates so-called maximum likely
destiny won't be consistent for that
underlying parameter goes back to Nathan
Scott 1948 and just a few years later
though key from Wolfowitz showed you
could do a trick you've got a lot of
those theta parameters and if you
instead of just treating him as unknown
quantities you treated them as unknown
quantities that came from a distribution
and you accounted for the fact that
there was such a distribution even if
you didn't know it you could get a
estimate that now is it's still an MLA
maximizing estimate but it's
acknowledging that the Thetas are coming
from a distribution they're essentially
random effects and you could get
consistent estimates of the unknown so
there was something just about having
lots of parameters when you add them you
ought to treat them as if they're from a
population that turned out to be
important now here's another related
thing that happened long ago to here's a
parameter I saw the story in three
dimensions there's three unknown related
but separate problems the three unknown
quantities theta one theta two and I'm
gonna get three data points d1 d2 d3 and
the sampling model is that the data are
independent centered on theta so d1 is a
data measurement that's estimating Zeta
one due to is this many theta 2 T 3 is
estimated see it sorry there are
independent things so z1 has no effect
on d2 and so on the little choked code
chunk on the right is actually trying to
simulate that it simulates this for a
couple for various status I in fact in
this little code I want to fix one of
the theta one fixed data to and I'm
gonna run on a grid of theta 3 to show a
picture I simulated up some data now the
question is if I used the data I wanna I
want to use the data somehow to estimate
the unknown quantities the Thetas
there's no sigh in this story there's
just unknown Thetas I could use the
standard estimate which is the data
themselves as estimates of their
expected values that's the standard
estimate which I I
calculating this code and I look at
error of of that estimate and in a way
I'll show in a second and then there's
another one a Bayes style estimate I'll
call it just based Eyal it's the data
but I shrink it a little bit just like
back in this tack problem where there
was that shrinkage there's a little
string kits here that is a factor that
in fact depends on the data now this is
a plot of the error the promise that
were the separate but related problems
had nothing to do with each other then
noise had nothing to do with it
but I'm going to assess the error of an
estimator by combining the problems
together and look at the average squared
difference between an estimator and the
thing it's estimating accumulated up
over the three different problems I find
it the standard estimator that mean
squared error is in the blue here
according to that simulation
I'm thing fader 1 theta 2 and I'm just
letting say 2/3 bear just because it's
hard to draw in three dimensions if
instead I was looking at the error and
out of the standard estimator but the
error here of the Bayes estimator I get
a base style estimator I'll call it you
get a uniformly smaller uniformly
smaller so this is a fundamental finding
from way back that if performance
evaluation considers all the tasks at
once all those related but separate
problems then the ideal procedure for
for the whole thing is not taken by
assembling the ideal procedures for each
problem taken in isolation a fundamental
fact that Sam Stein figured out and that
in fact you can actually do better in
frequency terms by using some kind of a
Bayesian style procedure okay how does
this actually work
well go back to the key for wolfwood
story you've got a bunch of related but
separate problems I've unknown
quantities data and I'm going to now
treat them as if they come from a
distribution in order to try and get
some benefit but of course in reality I
don't know that I know the data but I
wouldn't know the distribution that
generated them of course I have data so
maybe I could somehow or other estimate
that distribution
now as I've estimated it now I can think
like a Bayesian and say well I have that
distribution called Jade which
is essentially like informally a prior
distribution before I get data
essentially associated with all the
parameters so I can do a Bayesian style
calculation by working out the posterior
proportional to that prior times the
likelihood piece and here this is the
borrowing information part this actually
I'm doing inference on a single unit but
this is the this has acquired
information from all the other units in
this and this two-stage process
okay so borrow information is used a lot
in genomics I'm just going to close out
with an example RNA seek which is used
for measuring transcripts quickly we get
samples of cells messenger RNAs are
extracted they're converted to cDNA
they're read by the next-gen sequencing
reads those reads were lined at the
genome we get we get some measures rough
raw measurements of how frequent those
RNAs are in the sample of cells we have
to do some computations you get
abundance estimates you'll get multiple
samples together you'll normalize them
to account for sampling the specific
artifacts and then get down here and to
a problem of differential expression we
want to know which genes are
significantly differentially expressed
across different conditions than the
basic data structure that comes into the
calculation we've got jeans on the rows
got different samples along here and
those samples can be bundled up into
multiple conditions the basic
measurement after all that processing is
in basic measure of expression abundance
of a chain I in a sample I'm going to
just say briefly something about a
popular technique called a/b seek which
is deploying one of these information
sharing tools in the context of
expression and it's it's a popular one
because it has some nice statistical
properties that you can get rid of those
places let me say quickly I've at my
11:50 but I'm just going to just finish
up with a couple of slides on the
structure of this if that's okay Alex
thanks okay so how does the structure of
this thing go you got multiple cell
conditions
you've got gene level parameters so
these are per am
that have something to do with the
distribution of the expression
measurements in each condition
replicated replicated expression
profiles in various conditions one
condition two and so on and each gene I
is going to have some property so for
example if we took the negative binomial
distribution which is an over his first
naturally a natural distribution to use
for count data I show for two different
Thetas here possibly two different
conditions on a given gene what what the
sampling distribution of accounts might
be like for a different expression for
expression values here if theta C was if
point one was the expression then if
they two 0.1 what's the value then this
would be the fluctuation we'd expect to
see for of expression measurements in
that condition
so at issue so this is a natural
probability distribution yes many people
use it but how can you use it in a way
to borrow strength
at issue are you know you want to find
genes where there may be really some
difference in the status between
conditions so coming to the borrowing
strength part we we have a bunch of
related but separate problems those
being that related all the different
genes and we have parameters theta on
one for each gene and each one is a
vector over the different conditions and
the key structure of EB ready BC is to
do a first discrete mixing over
so-called patterns of agreement and
disagreement between the condition level
distributions and then for any latent
variables so that that's a finite sum
here I'll give it a quick example of
that subsequently and then you'll still
have unknowns Thetas even if if you even
forgiven pattern you'll have unknown
Thetas and they'll come out of some
mixing distribution that's called a b c
k-- also has some extra bells and
whistles that have a license nicely and
some other things i won't say anything
about so that's a specific structural
model for that distribution g and we
want to learn that from the data so we
use the n algorithm to do it once we've
learned it we can apply Bayesian style
calculation what's the probability of a
given pattern given data and here's
where the patterns come in for instance
of how one pattern if you have two
conditions one pattern is that the theta
is on
that gene for the two conditions are the
same this is the no differential
expression that there's there's no real
difference between the two conditions in
the average expression of the gene or
another pattern might be there really is
a difference in expression on the
average between those two conditions in
the expression of that gene basic null
hypothesis alternative hypothesis at the
gene level but the key thing about ABC
is it's leveraging all the information
across the genome to try and improve
sensitivity and improve statistical
properties of the final procedure a part
of that our local so-called local fdr's
probability of the null being true given
the data and the list of discovered
genes would be the things where that no
probability is small and then if it
smells small then there's a high
probability of the alternative so these
are posterior probabilities calculated
in the model and there's a bunch of
nifty formulas that you can work out for
those probabilities in the case that's
that's considered this just shows in a
stem cell example how it would deploy
where there's two conditions human
embryonic stem cells induced pluripotent
stem cells different genes on this axis
these genes were discovered by the EBC
Canales of 5% FDR and there's some nice
features about that about power and
robustness that other methods don't have
such good properties line that's pretty
quick summary of that I want to just go
to my final couple slides I'm closing
remarks and I appreciate your attention
benefits of Bayesian analysis handling
uncertainty as I've tried to describe
its absolute a problem where you've got
a whole bunch of things you don't know
and you go to a marginal posterior
structure combining different sources of
information of data that's base is
natural for that using the rules of
probability borrowing strengthen you
have many related but separate problems
and how you can use the collection of
those to improve their statistical
properties there's a whole bunch of
issues or computational challenges where
a lot of learning statistical machine
learning procedures have involve
optimization base and procedures use a
lot of integrations so there's some
different issues that come up and
there's a lot of challenges data science
challenges they're a big issue which I
think it is something we all need to
think about as we do this is that this
is all built on model specific
patience and you can make mistakes when
you specify probability model even the
specification might be too simple if
it's so simple you're not gonna learn
much new from some and compared to some
simple procedure if it's too complicated
well you risk all kinds of things you
risk making mistakes and the deployment
of it you risk that it's it doesn't
respect the properties of the data it's
sufficiently well so there's risks
associated and then the question in any
given situation are the risks of making
a screwy model specification do they
outweigh the benefits of improve power
or improved sensitivity and then finally
this is last I'll say the unknown so you
don't know you don't know Bayes is all
about unknowns and knowns and a joint
probability distribution over all those
things worried prior is the
probabilities fuchsine of the things
that you don't know and then the
likelihood is the probability of the
data that you'll get to know conditional
on what you don't know and you work out
a posterior distribution of what you
don't know given what you know except it
doesn't work if one of the you can't put
a prior down on something you don't know
if you don't know that you don't know it
and this is a fundamental issue that we
have to deal with the way it's dealt
with him in practice is is essentially
two diagnostic procedures obviously you
know all analyses are facing this thing
but we have to be upfront about it and
so many model-based calculations we ever
attempt to do we need to accompany them
predictive checks and Diagnostics to
make sure that we're not really fooling
ourselves I just want to end by
dedicating this these this short lecture
to Steve Feinberg who passed away too
soon last year he was a tremendous
figure had done tons of things for the
field of statistics generally in data
science and Bayesian analysis and he had
a positive impact on lots of people's
careers and I want to thank him for his
contributions and then I just want to
say thanks again to you all for
listening and I know it was quick but I
the slides are available for you to look
over and there are some papers that I
cited during
so thanks very much thanks Michael that
was a great overview for Bayesian
inference and you covered a lot of
ground in a very short amount of time so
and I appreciate the great job you did
explaining a lot of the more challenging
concepts in this space we have time for
one quick question which is somewhat
linked to the last point that you
brought up about unknowns and I guess
the challenge that we have a lot of
times when we're dealing with datasets
is one of missingness and sparseness and
so I don't know if there are any new
techniques that you could comment on in
terms of from the Bayesian perspective
of how to deal with with those two well
very separate issues but if they're
they're recommendations or suggestions
you could make in that regard well I
gather next week I think Lance Weiler is
going to be talking about missing this
so I'm sure he'll have more useful
things to say about the first issue
about missing this but you're you're
right I mean very often where you're
trying to do your statistical analysis
is in a kind of a gray zone where
there's really a lot of stuff you don't
have that you would like to have and in
all that's a challenge it's also a bit
of an opportunities like what else are
you going to do if you the Bayesian
strategy provides it's sort of general
approach and then then the you know
there's a lot of Liberty that you have
in terms of how you approach it in what
you do depends so much on the context of
the situation exactly what is the
relevant information that you have or
the relevant information that you don't
know what
how can you usefully summarize the data
down what parts of data should do not
have summarized the way so it's I think
you know you need to you need to sit
yourself in this kind of a Goldilocks
scenario where you know the model might
be too simple the model might be too
complicated if you have if the problem
that you're addressing is sufficiently
important you have enough
time to think of hard about it and you
could try something like this and
essentially what you need to do is write
down some kind of probability structure
for all those things that you don't know
and exactly what that would look like I
mean that depends very much on the
context doesn't it I do I would say that
you know in some classical probability
models like regression models where
sparsity is an issue that's very often
discussed with these penalized
estimation procedures lassos and all
that that more fully bayesian tools for
understanding the you know good
procedures in those situations are have
recently been I think under just
discovered and and debated so there's a
group of work that's doing a lot with
that there's Nick pulsons group in
Chicago that's done a bunch of
interesting things so there's the role
in the structure of prior distributions
when there sparsity so that's that is an
active area maybe that's as much as I
can usefully say about it at the moment
but yeah it's a good question great well
we're we're at 10 o'clock so I want to
thank you for your time and we'll end
here ok thanks Alex thank you